una nueva era para la otan tras cuatro
años de tensiones con donald trump en la
primera cumbre de la alianza con joe
biden a bordo los aliados elevaron su
tono contra china y rusia a los que
calificaron de autoritarios chinos
scrolling inflando la creciente
influencia de china y las políticas
internacionales presentan desafíos para
la seguridad de la alianza de la otan
johnson y poulter eng gastón komet mans
pedimos a china que respete sus
compromisos internacionales y actúe
responsablemente incluso en los dominios
espaciales cibernético marítimo de
acuerdo con su papel como gran potencia
en chipping with these roads a someter
por hayden quien promete fortalecer la
otan instó antes del evento a plantar
cara china y a su creciente poderío
militar mientras que concluyó que rusia
continúa siendo el enemigo número uno
del bloque
[Música]
compartir con nuestros aliados lo que le
transmitirá el presidente putin que no
estoy buscando un conflicto con rusia
pero que responderemos si rusia continúa
con sus actividades
dañinas y no dejaremos de defender la
alianza transatlántica o de ponernos de
pie por los valores democráticos gareth
williams los aliados también expresaron
su necesidad de hacer frente a los
ataques cibernéticos procedentes
principalmente desde territorio ruso de
igual forma acordaron pautar un
protocolo de retiro de sus tropas en
afganistán y fijar una hoja de ruta
contra el cambio climático